now you're going to write the code to
make sure that the users logged in if
they try to use the save profile
function look for the places mark to do
too in the save profile method in the
conference API class you're going to
want to go ahead and add final user user
that's the first argument to save
profile the user argument has to be the
first argument and the argument that
defines the data structure of the input
fields is the second argument and in our
case that's profile form then go ahead
and add the check to make sure that the
user is logged in if the user is now
throw an unauthorized exception
exception you'll also want to get the
user ID and the user's email out of the
user object that gets passed in and then
use the user ID and email to set the
appropriate fields test your app by
using the API Explorer on localhost you
should find that when you try to use the
save profile method you must be logged
in and you can use that simulation
button in the top right of the api's
explorer to simulate logging in when
you've made your code changes and
verified they work on localhost
go ahead and deploy to app spot then go
ahead and enter your app ID here so that
you'd acity can test your app